white house press secretary said even
after vaccines
we will have to mask in social distance
isn't the point of a vaccine that it
changes things for the better
that's our friend holly uh asking the
right questions as
she always does yeah i mean i have to
say
i'm a little bit cautious about this
because i still don't think we know
where we are
with respect to kovid and
yes ideally the whole point of the
vaccines
is to get us out of this mess
on the other hand we know very little
about you know
what happens downstream of these
vaccines we're going to start pushing
this virus around evolutionarily by
denying it access to people who've all
had the same vaccine which is going to
cause it to change and so you know
it's not it's not binary right the
immunity
uh is valuable i'm not saying
that we won't have our trust abused and
be told
to you know to modify our behavior even
when it's not
epidemiologically necessary i think
that's a risk but it's not clear to me
that given how precarious things are
that
um you know i mean for one thing we
haven't even done the basics here
we don't know yet if the vaccines
actually block transmission
they seem to reduce symptoms in the
people who've had the vaccines and
hopefully
also the likelihood of them getting it
but if they have it
we don't have any evidence that it
blocks
transmission i think it would be super
surprising if it didn't
yeah like really really surprising but
um but i think there's still no clinical
evidence for that
but we also i mean we haven't even
talked about whether or not
it makes sense for people who've had
covid to have the vaccine
which you know i mean but this is
another thing that just being said well
of course you need to get the vaccine
right and um
i mean i can i can think of mechanisms
that would actually make it
and certainly there is the unhedged risk
and there is every possibility that
having had covid actually gives you the
protection the vaccine would give you
anyway so it's really unclear to me
especially in light of the fact that we
apparently have a problem with the
amount of vaccine
right right there's all sorts of
arguments why we might want to at least
think twice
with respect to people who've already
been sick yeah no i'll just uh yeah
i'll say again that the three groups
that are easy for me
to say really be cautious
like really consider not is children no
pregnant women no and if you've already
had coved
consider the risks with that information
as part of your risk assessment yes
with you know the wild card of your
you're triggering the immune system with
a protein
your immune system is already primed to
react to
so um
i mean you know just to just to be clear
about this
i'm not saying the following thing does
happen but i'm saying
the following thing is plausible and
therefore deserves
to be eliminated as a possibility rather
than just assumed not to be a
possibility
if you get a vaccine and it causes the
production
of spike protein in order to inform your
immune system but your immune system is
already primed to react to that spike
protein the spike proteins that you
produce
in order to create that reaction may gum
up
the cells of your immune system which
are primed to react to it and it could
make you
more prone to covet am i saying it
happens no or is it possible that it
could promote an autoimmune response
itself
which is always the danger here you're
talking about a system either of those
which are different possible outcomes
neither which is good
yeah so uh in any case
i don't know how we ended up in this
ridiculous predicament but
here we are